We Begin this NewsHour here in Doha
where a major prisoner swap between the
U.S and Iran is underway after two years
of indirect negotiations Tehran is
freeing five Iranian Americans that
Washington says have been unjustly
detained the U.S is expected to release
five Iranians from its jails Oman Qatar
and Switzerland have all played a part
in facilitating negotiations between
Iran and the United States three of the
five American prisoners have been named
they all face charges of Espionage in
Iran
they and their families deny the charge
though in turn five Iranians that
Washington accuses of secretly working
for Tehran will be released they include
a political scientist a college
professor and an exporter
the US released Iranian funds that were
frozen in South Korea too now that money
first went to Switzerland and then to
Qatar six billion dollars of Iranian oil
revenue is now in a bank account in Doha
the U.S says Tehran can only use that
money for humanitarian needs
let's go live to Imran Khan who's at the
airport here in darasa Imran as I was
explaining through that graphic a lot of
moving pieces is it now in process
absolutely let me just show you where I
am right now I'm at Doha International
Airport the planes likely to arrive on
that Runway over there where it will tax
you to perhaps where that plane you can
see uh from there the freed prisoners
will be taken into that terminal
building just over there this all began
when six billion dollars of Iranian
funds were released to a Cattery bank
account but even that was complicated
those funds were seized in South Korea
under sanctions lawed by the Americans
they were then transferred under this
deal to Switzerland Switzerland then
transferred those funds to Qatar on
receipt The Prisoner exchange was
allowed to take place they're flying in
from Tehran it's about a two-hour
Journey it's unclear whether the plane
has actually taken off or not but
there's six billion dollars is actually
very controversial within the US
Republicans are saying it's effectively
a ransom payment for the Prisoners the
Biden Administration saying it's not a
ransom payment this is simply the only
way to get these prisoners freed now
when they're in that terminal building
they'll meet with representatives of the
Cattery delegation plus the U.S embassy
here and members of the state department
once that happens they're likely to go
fairly quickly back to the United States
where if previous prison exchanges are
anything to go by they'll be given a
medical evaluation and a security
debriefing now president raisi has been
speaking he says that the Pres the
prisoners are in good health and that
this is a good deal for all sides but
it's also controversial in Iran and once
again it comes down to that six billion
dollars the Iranians are only allowed to
access those funds for humanitarian
reasons now present rice here said these
are these funds for the benefit of the
Iranian people but the Americans say if
there's any hint that the funds are
being used for say for example weapons
purchases then they'll ask the catteries
to cut off those funds
all right good stuff there Imran Khan
from the airport in Doha
let's now hear from the Iranian foreign
minister who confirmed the prisoner swap
is taking place
foreign
policy we have unlocked our frozen
assets from South Korea today God
willing These funds will be in the hands
of our government and people and this
government will spend it accordingly to
the needs of the people
is a senior research fellow at the
center for Middle East strategic studies
joins us by Skype from Tehran good to
have you with us so controversial deal
as our reporter was saying how is this
being viewed in Iran
uh well Sammy this is quite important
because you know uh the timing of the
this development is important and it
seems that yet again as what happened to
the 2015 nuclear deal again the
exchanges and the interaction is taking
place between Iran and the United States
and we are seeing a diminishing role
from for the Europeans in the engagement
regarding the nuclear negotiations as
well as in the region uh this is the
final phase of the prisoner swap but
this could be a beginning for extended
and further talks on nuclear
negotiations as well as lifting the
sanctions against Iran but there's an
issue whether that the Americans will be
able to do with before their election
in the U.S or not at least I think the
talks can move in direction of the
targets and the goals of that 2015
nuclear deal and this is quite important
so the Explorer effect is important in
this regard and this can be a new
beginning for further talks between Iran
and the United States however in the
Iraq I was going to ask you about that
if this could be the basis for a
continuation of negotiations on other
issues
yes uh exactly on the sideline of the
United Nations uh General Assembly
there's the possibility of holding in
direct talks uh and continuing the
negotiations uh uh of vis-a-vis
and I think this is a process which will
need more time and while there has been
some discussions about the escalation
about you between Iran and the United
States I think this can contribute to
that process uh but how long it will
take it depends on the both parties but
this is important that as I said this is
taking place between Iran and the United
States and this will depend on the role
that Europeans can play in this regard
we are have been seeing some signs that
they have been also let's say making
their own approach toward Iran a bit
more mild there following the protests
taking place actually one previous year
and the timing is important because this
is happening at the anniversary of those
on wrestling protests in Iran and this
somehow suggests that their calculations
have been changing toward Iran and they
have been shifting to war toward
interaction with Iran how critical will
it be the issue of who decides how this
money is spent the six billion that has
been unfrozen and what constitutes
humanitarian needs
uh well this is quite clear semi because
there have been discussions that how
they can spend this money Iran and
American size what they have in common
is that these are going to be spent for
non-sanctioned goods and I I have been
hearing from Iranian officials that will
suffice them to to be able to buy the
Commodities that they need in the
country so and there will not be any
specific problem in this regard uh so
generally you know we can put it that it
can be used the amount of money for
non-sanctioned goods which can include
the humanitarian Goods or the others as
well which are not been under sanctions
given that we've got elections coming up
in the US given that there's been
criticism within the us over this deal
particularly the allegations that the
Iranians simply held people as hostages
rather than arresting people who there
were reasonable grounds to suspect
they'd done something wrong given all of
this background that's going on in the
US do you think that by the
administration really has a lot of scope
to make any progress with Iran
uh well this is one of the uh problems
that father's Administration has had so
far and that's why they have not been
able to make a decision on Reviving The
Nuclear deal but they say that this is a
ransom but let's not forget that this is
Iran's it owns money and this is not
something extra they want to demand from
the United States
and the from Iranian perspective the the
view is that that's the American side
who has tried to connect this prisoners
issue to the money they could have
released Iranian money beforehand they
can and then they could focus on
prisoners only
so and the Iran wants it the money that
comes from its uh you know selling its
own to other countries and this is not
something extra that it demands uh so
it's
exactly vice versa here in Tehran and
they said that Americans have tried to
help hostage you know Iranian money by
let's say uh bringing up other issues
and they were hoping to do this after
the nuclear deal was finalized but due
to the failure in Reviving the 2015
nuclear agreement they decided to make
this happen maybe they could use this as
a card in their elections and this is a
kind of let's say politicizing
humanitarian issue and this is uh what
is being brought up into Iran
criticizing by the administration all
right we'll leave it there thank you so
much for your thoughts on that Abbas
aslani
thank you Sam now cutter has mediated in
several long-running conflicts in 2008
street battles erupted in Beirut between
government forces Hezbollah and other
militias Qatar hosted talks that led to
a framework for parliamentary elections
they were held the following year in
2011 the Sudanese government
Representatives met Rebel leaders from
Darfur in Doha their agreement called
the Doha document for peace was one of
several attempts to mediate the
long-running conflict in Western Sudan
in 2020 you'll remember the U.S and
Taliban officials meeting in Qatar for
the first time after 20 years of war now
they signed the Doha courts agreeing to
the withdrawal of U.S forces and a
commitment that Afghanistan would not be
used to launch attacks against the U.S
the agreement was negotiated without the
participation of the then Afghan
government now in 2022 representatives
from 40 different opposition groups in
Chad came to dalha to meet with Chad's
military government they agreed to a
cease fire to open reconciliation talks
the country's main Rebel group called
fact didn't take part but didn't did
they well it didn't sign rather well
is a former Qatari ambassador to the
United Nations he joins us now live from
Paris good to have you with us so first
of all it took almost two years of
indirect negotiations what finally
enabled this deal to come together
well uh thank you for uh hosting me uh
and uh this is a very good news for the
families of the prisoner and I am happy
for them but you know they are you know
the process of this in such a happy
ending took quite a long time
and it was the trust to the two parties
of the uh gold offices of Qatar that led
to such ending
as a matter of fact you know for the
past two two years we've been observing
Qatar officials moving back and forth
between Tehran and Washington DC and
such outcome is good for both countries
especially the people who are you know
happen to be a prisoner and their
families and is also good for our region
because the more we
solve a problem or a problem solved
around us the more our region become
more stable and for me I think you know
this is a good day all right we
understand as part of the deal six
billion dollars is going to be held in
Qatari Banks who decides how that money
can be spent what constitutes
humanitarian needs
as a matter of fact these are technical
issues which I am not believing to but I
am sure there is a mechanism where Qatar
will be on board then to make sure that
the money is spent only for the purposes
they were agreed to uh of course you
know the future will be the judge but I
hope everybody will be committed to
whatever they committed themselves to so
because Qatar in this situation is a
guarantor that
such money and such fund will be spent
on Goods which will help the Iranian
people
there's been some expectation or hope
that maybe this could form the basis of
negotiations on other issues is Qatar
trying to play a role to try and resolve
issues between the US and Iran on wider
other issues
well I am sure you know Qatar has been
involved a negotiation between these two
countries and Qatar has then allied with
the United States and the event the
neighbor of Iran
will be happy to play any role which
will bring them together and create a
stable region you see we we are
surrounded by a lot of a lot of problems
in our region and it's time that we we
get rid of this instability and it's
time that people work together
governments work together so uh you know
peaceful and they will be prepared
investment will grow and the cooperation
will be there the new the new languages
having said that we understand that this
is good for Iran but also for the for
President Biden since you know they
election is coming next year this is
something which you can show to to his
people though it is very beneficial to
the prisoner and I am happy for them all
right thank you so much for Ambassador
for talking to us
thank you